un billet de 20 euros un billet de 10
euros
ont plus l'air de billets de monopoly en
2022 la comparaison prêterait à sourire
mais vingt ans plus tôt les débuts sont
hésitants en décembre 2001 les passages
en caisse sont plus longs mais la
préparation s'est faite bien en amont
dans les commerces cette grande surface
avait prévu double affichage des prises
tant d'euros et qu'elle se réservait aux
fonctions de la monnaie utilisée
[Musique]
on a fait d'abord tout ce qui était
formations dites commerciales pour ce
qu'on appelle le basculement de nos prix
en euros ça s'est passé semaine 44 c'est
à dire fin octobre ça c'est la 1ère
partie la deuxième partie c'est toute la
formation qu'on a fait sur nos hôtesses
de caisse dont qui a duré à peu près
depuis le mois de septembre c'est 600
heures de formation
c'est pas grave à montigny le bretonneux
en ce 1er janvier 2002 le passage
officiel à l'euro s'est fait dans la
douceur et chacun avait mis en place
leurs propres techniques pour ne pas se
perdre cette boulangerie avait notamment
installé un convertisseur s'ils le
voyaient penserai toujours obligé de
retourner ça pour qu'il le voyait tout
alors bon là comme ça ils voyent ce que
j'ai fait au plan pratique c'est j'ai un
porte-monnaie pour les 0 et au
porte-monnaie pour les francs il vous
fallait à partir de là ça va premier
achat en euros mais aussi premier autres
et les commerces sont fermés mais
certains saint quentinois ne découvre
cette nouvelle monnaie j'avais pas de
kit j'avais rien acheter si quelques
pièces en mai mais c'est tout pourquoi
du smatah ses parcs ses auditeurs oui en
fait tout à fait oui pour reprendre
avoir pour demain et les banques notées
une ruée dans toute la france le 2
janvier plus de 2 millions de retraités
et effectué les français avaient
jusqu'au 17 février pour échanger l'an
dernier francs et vingt ans après
comment les yvelinois viril avec l'euro
j'ai l'impression que le passage à
l'euro
a permis d'augmenter les prix de façon
exponentielle avec mes études où je suis
allé à l'étranger donc ça va bien aider
en plus avec les banques qui sont à
ranger entre temps pour éviter qu'on est
des frais supplémentaires ou ce genre de
choses ça m'a l'air ça veut valider
quand on a acheté notre maison c'était
en francs et maintenant pour savoir en
euros il faut faire le calcul on dit
tiens c'est plus dur quoi en 2002 comme
en 2022 l'augmentation des prix est la
première inquiétude s'ils ont bien
augmenté les salaires aussi les chiffres
de l'insee ou de la banque mondiale
montrent que l'inflation est restée à
des niveaux très bas